this one is by popular request so
triumph of the will and the cinematic
language of propaganda triumph of the
will is not a triumph of filmmaking I
just want to lay that out before we even
start chances are good that you're
familiar with triumph of the will by
reputation but have never actually
watched it beyond referential clips and
a sizable portion of that reputation is
in its value as an advancement of the
art of filmmaking this is propaganda
like that belief is in and of itself
propaganda Nazi sympathizers spent a lot
of time between the film's release in
1935 and the war promoting the idea of
triumph of the will as an advancement of
filmmaking it was an intentional message
to promote Nazi state art as superior to
suggest that the Nazi mechanism could
produce better more proficient art than
the artists the Nazis were busy throwing
in jail it is however not a triumph of
filmmaking it is a triumph of budget
none of the ideas or techniques were new
it is simply that no one had previously
thrown enough money and resources at
propaganda on this scale before we'll
come back to this and develop it in more
detail but I want to be upfront with the
fact that you should be highly
suspicious of any messaging surrounding
propaganda okay so vocabulary groundwork
we're going to make a distinction about
what we mean when we say propaganda
broadly speaking propaganda is just any
goal driven ideological message and a
lot of stuff incidentally falls under
that umbrella for example any official
message from an activist community meets
the literal definition signs encouraging
you to like pick up after your dog so
the first thing that we need to make
note of is the textural difference
between the literal definition of
propaganda and how people actually use
the word contextually propaganda is used
derisively it's not merely used to
describe the literal characteristics of
some text or another but carries with it
a value
judgments with the implicit
understanding that propaganda is bad
mimetic li propaganda represents not
just rhetoric but some degree of
dishonesty not an attempt to persuade
but to deceive not an attempt to inform
but to inflame and even by this metric
there's still plenty that qualifies as
propaganda from white nationalists
spreading false statistics about crime
to corporations trying to paper over the
damage they do to vloggers being paid to
pretend to like a video game so what
we're going to do here is draw a fine
line between propaganda and propaganda
the distinction being a difference
between general propaganda and
propaganda generated by and in service
of government's I feel like this is an
important distinction to make because
there's a potent contextual difference
between say the propaganda tracks and
memes spread by hate groups and those
spread by the state that distinction is
order of magnitude the sheer reach and
spending power at the disposal of
governments is so far beyond the scope
of even corporations that it's the
laughable comparison the US federal
government's annual revenue is three
point six trillion dollars the largest
corporation in the world Walmart sees an
annual revenue of four hundred eighty
two billion dollars the ten largest
corporations combined still fall almost
a trillion dollars short global box
office revenue comes in around thirty
eight billion dollars and Pirates of the
Caribbean for is ranked as the most
expensive movie ever made at three
hundred and seventy eight million
dollars but on the scope of federal
budgets especially those related to the
military its budget is a rounding error
now this isn't even touching on the
power that governments have to enact and
enforce the underlying policies that
propaganda supports the point is that
large motivated governments can
effortlessly outspend
any other organized entity on the planet
and as a result their potential for
producing and disseminating propaganda
exists on an entirely different plane of
operation than any other form when you
add in the potential outcomes of that
Buganda influencing the lives of
millions or even billions of people the
stakes to dwarf everything else is for
this reason that we're not going to be
talking about propaganda in the abstract
but rather this very specific kind of
propaganda and with that established
triumph of the will
[Music]
Leni Riefenstahl film triumph is villain
isn't the beginning of propaganda it's
not even the beginning of motion-picture
propaganda well heck it's not even
refinish tiles first propaganda film for
the Nazis and I'm going to use that as a
segue into some contextual history in
1933 refinished all documented the
annual Nazi Nuremberg rally in the films
their seed is globins victory of faith
however that film is significantly less
well known filmed at the August 1933
rally celebrating Adolf Hitler's
appointment to the position of
Chancellor of Germany in January of that
year the film heavily features founding
Nazi Party leader Anson Rome her own
would be executed a year later in July
1934 during the night of long knife a
sweeping ideological purge of socialist
and working-class leadership in the Nazi
Party after which it was ordered that
all known copies of victory of space be
destroyed as part of an attempt at
rewriting history
erasing Rome's contributions to the Nazi
Party due to the high profile of many of
the people killed in the purge it was
impossible to cover up the illegal
executions so Hitler had the cabinet
just make them legal after the fact a
month after the purge August 1934
President Hindenburg died and by the
middle of August the rolls of president
and Chancellor were merged making Hitler
both the head of state and the head of
government with all of that in mind a
number of very high-profile crimes
followed by a complete restructuring of
the government in September 1934 Hitler
and his party had a vested interest in
reinforcing the perceived legitimacy of
the regime and preparing the populace
for the wars that were to come and to
that end they hired recent Stahl to make
a second propaganda documentary out of
the now annual Nuremberg rally
now let's talk about the language of
propaganda from a filmmaking perspective
propaganda uses all the same grammar as
any other example of the medium contrast
association implication these are all
the bread and butter of assembling any
visual narrative as an example we're
going to look at something a little
lighter than Nazis and take a look at
Return of the King
so Return of the King has a scene where
Dennis Thor has sent Faramir out to die
on the battlefield and the film cross
cuts between the battlefield and the
holida palace where Dennis Thor is
having dinner the three main things of
interest are dinosaurs eating Pippin
singing and Faramir writing the film
pays particular interest to the squishy
sounds and sloppy process of dinosaurs
eating which when juxtaposed with
Faramir suicide mission creates somatic
implications that Denethor is a careless
sloppy glutton who consumes the lives of
the people around him he discards his
son's life with same grace as he
squishes a tomato where Pippin and
Faramir are highlighted by their faces
their percentages denethor is largely
viewed from severe angles and segmented
reduced to his hands and it's giant
consuming mouth a visual parallel
matched by the deformed orc gothmog
Denethor breaks bones and blood runs
down his chin images which are
juxtaposed with the blood streaking the
faces of the orcs preparing to slaughter
Farrah Mears troops this is all
compounded by Pippin song which
essentially just commentates the
contrast as it happened the messaging
here is pretty straightforward Denethor
is villainized a parallel is created
between him and New York's tech if
anything it's ridiculously heavy-handed
the point of this example is to drive
from the fact that there really is no
difference in the editing Grammer used
in one genre versus another the same
process of creating implications of
villainizing or lionizing through
juxtaposed imagery works the same
regardless where propaganda diverges is
in the nuances of how the message is
delivered one of the sand traps of
discussing ideology and cinema is the
demand of narrative story at least in
the European tradition requires conflict
characters must be
odd they must make mistakes their
opponents must get the better of them
things in some way shape or form need to
get bad need to entertain uncertainty in
a Return of the King a conventional
story dinosaurs actions must bring
Pippin and Gandalf and Faramir low in
order to create the tension that will be
relieved later in the story when the
conflict is resolved
however these basic mechanisms of
narrative tension are at odds with the
needs of propaganda because weakness
failure and uncertainty are an asthma to
the propagandist the subject of
propaganda has no arc but upwards they
begin strong and end stronger they crush
all that oppose them their opposition is
flimsy and victory is trivial they win
so much that the audience gets tired of
all the winning this is the point
triumph of the will is no different it
is interminable in its assertion of the
strength of the Nazi Party and the
promise of victory and the uselessness
of the opposition all right well
actually it is a little bit more
complicated see propaganda does still
require a worthy foe or more accurately
a foe that justifies the volume of force
that the propagandist is trying to rally
triumph of the will and Nazi ideology in
general is obsessed with both the
unstoppable might of the party and the
need for that unstoppable might to be
levied against the paradoxically weak
degenerates who secretly control
everything Umberto Eco in his 1995 essay
or fascism describes this particular
ideological quirk the followers must
feel humiliated by the ostentatious
wealth and force of their enemies
however the followers must be convinced
that they can overwhelm the enemies
thus by a continuous shifting of
rhetorical focus the enemies are at the
same time too strong and too weak
fascist governments are condemned to
lose Wars because they are
constitutionally incapable of
objectively evaluating the force of the
enemy now let's back up and revisit
previous accusation triumph of the will
is not a triumph of cinema but of
budgets one of the central arms of
attack that triumph of the wheel uses is
in its very essence its existence as a
grandiose long
Pence's complex production none of the
filmmaking ideas used were new putting a
camera in the back of a car wasn't new
tracking shots weren't new low angle
shots weren't new aerial shots weren't
new the only thing new was scope every
scene goes on and on for minutes at a
time there are not a few aerial shots
there are hundreds there is not a camera
observing the parade as it passes there
are dozens of cameras embedded in the
very fabric of the parade to the modern
viewer it may seem aimless and shoddily
paste with montages that just go on and
on and on long after the point is being
made but that's the point it is not
merely a demonstration of presence but a
volume the indulgence of it the
conspicuous cost is as much a message of
the film as any other intended to tell
the viewer that the economic might of
Nazi Germany is so great that even their
propaganda is casually one of the most
expensive productions to date every
visual implication of wealth strength
and power is made and then repeated and
repeated and repeated Hitler descends
from the majesty of the atom's the old
and weathered architecture of Nuremberg
is peppered with Nazi icons
tying the new regime to the perceived
wealth and stability of ages past
children gaze in awe on their glorious
humble leader a man so blessed by the
gods that even cats take notice of his
passing the Reich is juxtaposed with
churches with the pastoral column of the
Rising Sun with efficiency with a bounty
of food and of course with an endless
supply of soldiers troops March and
March and March and March the Nazi army
does not merely exist it goes on and on
and on and then on a little more after
that now there is no arc to the film
because there is no conflict look at us
we're amazing there is no story there is
only message oh it's mostly lies by the
way internally the Nazis were a mess
they had after all just assassinated a
number of their own high ranking off
and the army which outnumbered the SA
and SS was still very much on the fence
about their support for the regime
following the death of Hindenburg
Germany was still very much at risk of
tipping into a civil war between the
Nazis and the Vera knocked the whole
point of the rally was to make the film
and the whole point of the film was to
project an image of an unstoppable
overwhelming wealthy happy fed and
unified Nazi Germany to demoralize
opponents and embolden supporters in
fact there's a message back there that
you probably wouldn't even catch that
whole thing about the army the actual
German army the ver macht is barely in
the film there's one scene of cavalry
being inspected but that's about it all
the rest of that endless sea of troops
our SA and SS troops which were organs
of the Nazi Party not of the Armed
Forces it is a conscious exclusion meant
to establish a pecking order between the
Nazis and the Vermont to make the
potentially disloyal members of the army
feel small overwhelmed unimportant and
outnumbered throughout the film the
odious aspects of the Nazi ideology the
concentration camps which had already
been operating for a year by that point
the political assassinations the racism
these were all downplayed or absent left
unstated the message is clear and
singular we are strong and prosperous
and anything we choose to do is
justified because it works and religious
imagery is then tapped to consecrate
that justification with divine favor
historically this is also where we start
to really see the public beginning of
Nazi paganism with a parade of Nazi
flags being ceremony consecrated by
touching them to the blue tooth on a
flag that they claim to being carried by
the Nazis killed during the Beer Hall
Putsch now the relationship between the
Nazis and religion is super complex and
interesting and you should definitely
look into it lots of books out there on
the subject but if you can get your
hands on a copy definitely check out
irani as children it's a really
interesting short read about astrology
that's been out of print for decades and
the occult roots of Nazism the short of
it is that Nazism was a theological
goulash they made heavy use of Christian
symbology and tried to term the numerous
German churches into an organ of the
party through the confessional Church
but this was largely a means to a
end they didn't tap into Christian
imagery because they shared Christian
values they did it because those images
have emotional meaning to the people
simultaneously to this they were
co-opting any religious symbols that
they felt supported their own claim to
power adopting the disparate trappings
of both Odin ISM and Hinduism this goes
just as well for their approach to
science and their embrace of
pseudoscience it doesn't matter what
form it comes in as long as it reaches
the desired conclusion in the words of
Hannah Arendt science is only a
surrogate for power this is actually
important one of the main mechanisms of
propaganda is to plant the idea of
precedents to alter the audience's own
sense of history and the world and
appeal to the seemingly objective
authorities of God history and science
one of the most common uses of
propaganda is to make new institutions
seem much older than they really are by
injecting themselves and their ideas
into history
what Umberto Eco described as a cult of
tradition not the architecture is
monumental in design evocative of
classical Greek and Roman triumph of the
will places the new Nazi Party alongside
centuries old churches Nazi eschatology
dredges of Old Norse runes to suggest an
unbroken pure lineage between the
ancient and the present Nazi
pseudoscience says that the murder of
Jews and Roma is acceptable because of
blood the point of it all is to centre
the party in every aspect of life to
make the party the mouthpiece of the
gods this is why there's all that bunk
about riefenstahl being a visionary
director the legacy of triumph of the
will is muddled because it was
intentionally muddled the party was
trying to inject itself into everything
into history and to arch into religion
they made their own movie and had their
own critics praised it to make it
important
despite being funded entirely by the
government triumph of the will was
released commercially to distance it
from the party just enough to add a
patina of legitimacy
to suggest that Riefenstahl had captured
something unique and organic and it
worked to this day we continue to use
triumph of the will as our reference
point for the mental construct of the
Nazi Rouge
which I want you to think about that our
idea of the Nazis is deeply informed by
a propaganda film produced by the Nazis
for the explicit purpose of creating
that mental construct this right here is
exactly the image they wanted you to
think of when you thought of them
[Music]